one time the sensei was a 6:27 the next
day was like 629 oh my god and then the
third day was raining Alex Rodriguez
describing not one not two but three
times he practiced popping the question
- JLo he really makes an effort so do I
to kind of be there for each other and
it means a lot to me I planned it for
about six months
the former MLB star was a guest on
Tuesdays Tonight Show where he dished on
planning the big moment I rehearsed
three days in a row because I wanted the
sunset to be perfect but he didn't
rehearse alone I had my assistant
actually with me eventually he got it
down perfect and as he stated in his
adorable Instagram post announcing the
news he locked it down with a gigantic
engagement ring
[Music]
[Applause]
a source told ET after the couple was
engaged in March
Jennifer was shocked when a rod got down
on one knee she quote wasn't aware he'd
be proposing and as far as wedding
planning goes another source tells ET
their kids will play a big part in their
big day I think we're very alike in many
ways and I think that's what makes it
work and I think that's why people
respond to the fact that we got together
we're likely except I can't sing dance
and I don't look like her besides that
we're trained we complement each other
in a beautiful way and I couldn't have
asked for a better partner in this
[Music]